[Applause]
you know what i think i've realized uh
again again this is complete like me
just
off the gut there's no facts that back
this up whatsoever
but i think this is what trump is when
it comes to
race i think
trump is and maybe purposefully so
ignorant to the minority experience
in america and because
he is he doesn't have the same level of
empathy or compassion
that someone who has watched maybe their
black friend get harassed by the cops or
these types of things
so his mind he's like
no i just treat everybody equal like
remember back in the day when i was
partying with all the rappers and
everybody thought i was cool yeah i just
treated them like regular guys
and i think the rappers and stuff back
in the day we're all like yeah he's just
some rich dude he just treats you
regularly he don't even [ __ ] care
and i think they were kind of seduced by
that but they never had conversation
with trump about like
empowerment in these neighborhoods and
that kind of stuff like that so he i
don't
know if he's hateful of minorities
i do not think that he's empathetic
i actually think he's a marketing genius
but take that in and like
let's address that what do you guys
think about i don't i don't think i
think
maybe but he also doesn't i think he is
doesn't care his lack of empathy
no but like i think yeah he's just
looking at it as the main thing to me is
like
i know how to win i know how to market
myself as a winner move win
like talk about the man like not about
winning the election like truly like
like i remember it really the light bulb
went off for me when he said to black
people he was like
what do you got to lose just come to
like that was his pitch to black people
this pizza black people was like
we're gonna help you we're going to
figure out what i understand what you go
through
i understand the tough things about the
systemic racism that you've experienced
has created these environment
literally the thing was yeah it sucks to
just try it he didn't even try he didn't
even try to appeal
to the situation right it was literally
you have nothing to lose so you might as
well come on try it my way
right yeah i can see that perhaps maybe
he doesn't have contempt on like racial
lines but perhaps it's on
class lines i could see him much more so
i could see him perhaps having a lot
more to stay in for
poor people 100 and his like buildings
are like redlining and like they're not
letting like black people come in
it's wrapped up in racism obviously and
in that case he's probably racist but if
it was like a wealthy black dude
if dr dre wants to live in the building
please dr dre come on in that's what i'm
saying i think he understands cache and
celebrity
and is not going to stand up for the
right thing especially if it infringes
on like his uh
class now the tricky thing about class
is
at least his politics appear that he's
willing to turn a blind eye to poor
whites
in terms of his contempt right so he's
willing to
appease whatever it is that they need
right he's willing to pander to them
obviously for the votes now we're
talking about the votes but i do really
think it is maybe more tied up into
class
and i'm curious if all these rappers and
these like producers and like people
these black celebrities ever got the
feeling that he was racist back in the
day because they never spoke about it
right yeah and i'm sure they would have
there's no reason to protect him
not like he was doing anything for their
careers right i think the distinction to
make is that obviously
as we know like race is tied up in class
100
yeah 100 races tied up into everything
right but
i i just i think that that explains the
lack of empathy
i think there is an added layer with
race there's an added layer of i
judge people who i judge most people as
being beneath me if you're not at my
income level
even if you're black at my income level
i don't see you as equal i don't see you
as equal as i do an nba team owner
like if him and mark cuban there's like
a respect slash a little bit of fear
with cuban mm-hmm i don't think you
would have that with a billionaire black
dude
bob johnson or whoever he's like yeah
sure but you know like
i wha what is your like backing for that
i
i think he's a super rich guy super rich
people in my
limited experience they see class more
so than anything else but there's also a
limp like a little bit of
race tied into it like black people are
still a little bit beneath
me you know what i mean so it's like i
agree with akash but at the same time
in my head i can't point to an example
of why i feel that way it's almost like
you you know you just
have a feeling about a person yeah and
he gives that off
i'm wondering if that's your guy's
internalized bias based on experiences
that you've had with people in your
lives
whereas like mark and i our internalized
biases
is different because we're white yeah
right no it's possible
you've experienced maybe a rich person
like looking down on you that you're
just as wealthy as
right because of your race being
different
right where like we haven't had that
same experience or maybe we're paranoid
because it's happened before so when i'm
with a rich person but i feel like when
i'm with really rich people
there's there's already some like level
of condescension but i feel like there's
a little bit extra
right because i'm not white whereas if i
was white he'd be like i
and maybe it's cultural maybe i get this
guy but i think there's like an extra
layer with
really wealthy people of like i have
this yeah but i'm still white like
i've heard it like i heard like jay-z
mentioning songs like
when he got rich and they wouldn't even
let him get an apartment and try because
right
right right like jay-z at that level at
in time he was the drake at that time
yeah they were turning him down from
buying an apartment yeah in manhattan so
it's like
i don't think that would ever happen to
any rich white guy of course not no no
i'm not i'm not debating like the
the treatment and so i'm thinking
because trump
is a property owner he has that same
type of mind
state as though i wonder and again this
is
i think that could be a hundred percent
true but i wonder if
like what mark was saying before he's
looking that through the lens of
profitability
and through the lens of class rather
than through the lens of race
so as a or it could be both yeah or
most likely they're both intertwined
we're arguing like at what percentage
they they they tie in um like i wonder
if there's
a rich black dude that like believes all
the same [ __ ] trump believes
if they can't be friends i think they
can be friends but
again i always think there's a little
extra something say again isn't he cool
with tiger woods
yeah like a tiger woods or something
like that like i believe that that they
could have that
type of friendship or whatever like that
and again i just don't have any
proof to say otherwise i believe if
there's a rich black dude that's like
now we need to be empathetic to like the
the minority struggle in
the united states of america and i think
that he looks at that like ah let
everybody pick
them by their bootstraps and like you
know be accountable on this kind of [ __ ]
like that like i just don't think a lot
of these people
can step back and like consider why they
are where they are and why other people
aren't yeah and don't get me wrong maybe
the methodology of
i don't give a [ __ ] what treatment i've
had i'm gonna go out there and get it
maybe that works better
but it doesn't hurt to have some empathy
well i think the binary of trying to
think about people as racist or not
racist isn't really conducting yeah i
actually agree with you all that it
probably is more classes than anything i
think that's a small layer and i don't
think that
has anything to do with how he markets
himself as a politician
i think he's looking at it
sociopathically which is i know how to
market i know how to market my way to
being president i'm going to speak
to this large percentage of population
is a big void in the market and that
sometimes means he does racist things
yes like i don't think we should
discount that like he does racist things
and when he doesn't let black people go
into his apartment buildings that's a
racist racist even if it's dictated by
financial gain you're still choosing to
do a racist
act yeah even if the act isn't dictated
by the racism
right if he's going into it all right of
black people in the building then i'm
not going to get the same amount of
white investment because they don't want
to believe it live with the black people
all right i'd rather have the white
investment don't let the black people go
in here
i don't care if you're motivated by
money you still do some racist [ __ ]
yeah you got to be accountable for that
but a lot of times in our brains we
think like of kkk or not kkk
yeah that's right the binary is tricky
so it's like oh like you can do racist
behavior but still
not operate as a racist in most of your
life like you can have a black wife but
still
like have animosity or like behave in a
racist way or like profile someone in
your story and we all have
prejudice thoughts so it's also tricky i
think for us to individually judge
what at what degree of racist action are
you racist
yes there's yes it's like uh
you don't like i've have i've had
friends who all remain
you know nameless with these folks but
like they do not
stand for any racism towards black
people
right but they will be making asian
jokes bro
yeah the delivery guy is getting these
jokes right but any black
right any subtle black racism a joke on
an instagram post or anything
not tolerating it this is [ __ ] up this
is fine we're talking about black people
yeah i'm like but true don't talk about
me
i tried to keep your name but uh but you
know but there it is it's like they're
against racism that's anti-racism yeah
in one direction right but it shows that
it isn't a binary
then there are other there's other
places where there's for whatever reason
room for it
right you know so yeah maybe we
shouldn't look through p at people
through the like uh jamila hill lens
racist not racist right maybe we got to
start looking at people
as complex figures man yeah it's just
hard
well maybe if we don't look at them if
they are racist or they're not racist we
basically look at them through
i don't care if you're not racist if you
are willing
to take accountability and do a racist
act then we judge you based on that
like your decision to redline even if
you don't hate black people
it's a racist act it doesn't make you
racist but that's a racist act and we
got to hold you accountable for that
yeah i do yeah the idea that if you are
a trump supporter you're racist is just
like we're
crazy or or some like white kid who's
like rapping a song and then says the n
word in the song
that might be racist but i don't think
that makes the kid [ __ ]
he just didn't know he was listening
your statement so
i think the reason why people say that
oh if you're a trump supporter you're
racist
is because he uh energizes
racist so it's like now if you're
supporting the guy
who energizes there is a point at which
i think you have to have some empathy
for some people who are like
really poor white people who are
struggling who are like
this is the only guy who's who's cared
about me in 20 years
who's spoken to me so if some bad [ __ ]
is happening to other people that sucks
but this is the only guy that's ever
said to me that i matter
in a political arena since what who
knows
[ __ ] fdr so yeah so i feel spoken to
with this guy and that sucks that that's
happening
but that's we all compartmentalize but
that's basically what
you are like if i said to you yo india
is so [ __ ] poor dog you have no idea
the level of poverty you can't even wrap
your mind around it
a lot of people lebron james yo that
sucks
but i gotta worry about what's in my
people's best interests right now so
let me let me say something to that i
think that is completely
the reason why people are voting for him
i hundred percent i also think that you
can
i think that you can hold trump
accountable
for i don't want to say like uh you can
hold trump account for his own behavior
right but just as like you said he
enables racist remember he was just
saying that right
or he galvanizes them when he wasn't
letting black people
you know rent his places or buy his
places i don't know how much of that he
did i'd have to look into it but i'm
sure there's you know i've only heard of
the
instances on instagram on instagram
right so it's like but when that
happened
he's actually still enabling the races
he's siding with the races yeah right
because even if he doesn't hit
blackfield he's like wait a minute the
people who want to buy my [ __ ] hey black
people
i got y'all yeah yes so we know he has
potentially i have to look deeper into
it a history of
maybe he is zero hate but willing
to sacrifice his zero hate and what is
maybe right
for the greater goal which i think is
what akash was touching on which is
oh i got to do a little racist [ __ ] to
be president
oops
and it is an interesting thing that's
why you can
a black person or any person of color
can look at support of trump
and say oh you're racist to support this
guy
who but it's the exact same distinction
we were making sure
so it's like both statements are correct
real quick real quick i think this makes
this makes your point which is um you
could look at it as
i think you can say you are supporting a
racist i don't think you can say
it makes you racist correct because and
i think that's where there's pushback
i think if all these people that say
anybody who votes trump is a racist i
think if they just said
hey if you vote for trump you're
supporting a racist i think some really
poor people would be like man i wish i
didn't have to
but he's the only one who's saying he's
going to open up the factory and that's
the only [ __ ] job that i got or i
know how to do
i'm [ __ ] sorry i think they might
even go look i'm sorry
if that biting guy said he would open up
the factory i'd give you that [ __ ] in a
heartbeat and don't get me wrong there's
tons of
trumpers who are like yeah [ __ ] anybody
there's definitely trump supporters who
are racist i've had death threats from a
lot of them
that's a fact that but i i will still
not
do the if you vote for trump you are
racist and he's the one that gets
affected by the racism
that's the brave like if i say that
statement then [ __ ] like are
you just protected trump
he's the one that gets him i gotta keep
the same energy i can't switch up my
whole [ __ ] because i
the the fight and i agree with that it's
not it doesn't make you racist
but you are supporting a racist yo
you're supporting a guy
who who who is he's a racist who
sympathize with racist and pandas
racist if you say it like that and this
is this is kind of the cool thing that
we do with the the
weekly monologues is like we try to
slice things really thin yeah it's it's
almost like we're giving
people a look into like our workshop
yeah you know what i mean it was like
what could we say that actually both
sides would have to give up and agree
and i think you almost empathize with
someone who's so [ __ ] poor and
distraught that they gotta support a
racist
you live in this guy who sympathizes
with racism yeah like you you almost
you go ah [ __ ] how shitty is what you
got going on that that's your only
option
yeah you know and you also emphasize the
person who's like yo
they're this guy's cool like empowering
racist why would you
why would you support him you understand
that yeah
both sides are [ __ ] reasonable and
when we stop looking at through the
binary like you said
you realize that both sides can't have a
point yeah
man we're important
[Applause]